[Music]
welcome to another gay episode of
careful boys
where we have with a steve straight guy
green
or what is it the wrestling thing when
you get
hit i'm hooking up you got hit in the
face but that doesn't matter like
[Laughter]
that just made me stronger than ever
that's one of the best [ __ ] salamanca
uh
that character came to life man the guy
uh
he was he was hard to crack i'm not
gonna lie
so i
i know you guys are not the most easily
embarrassed
but can you remember anytime that
something embarrassing happened to you
in public and you were legitimately
embarrassed in public oh god do you guys
know about my mom at my boy scouts
meeting yeah yeah was she [ __ ] farted
yeah that you that was legit that's it
your mom [ __ ] breaks wind
that was that's very important to me
no i really care i really cared about
boy scouts
and at that time it's one of those where
like you're about to get in that age and
boy scouts is like you have young guys
and slightly older dudes and so you're
always trying to impress the older dudes
and it's one of those things where like
if you get caught with your pants down
you're getting roasted for the rest of i
don't know how long
so for me that mattered a lot and then
my parents are never at any of those you
know meetings or whatever and this time
i'm like they're getting promoted or
whatever
and then she farted and i'm like
i've never heard any other parent fart
but you
and you're someone that preaches
classiness and elegance all the time and
you just straight let one out well
analyzing that elegance did you know
what she was thinking at that moment she
didn't want indigestion she got [ __ ]
mad at me because i'm like uh she got
mad at me for getting mad at her
and i'm like why'd you do that like i
like you why can't you walk out or
whatever and she goes i didn't know it's
gonna happen i was just stretching and
i'm like when you stretch with only one
butt cheek you know what the [ __ ] you're
doing don't [ __ ] lie to me oh so she
was just trying to be like silent and it
didn't did she when she lifted up like
this she lifted up i've seen that exact
same motion
at home she knows what that was how loud
was it it was like [ __ ] movie loud
like [ __ ]
and everyone's like like american pie
yeah like that kind of [ __ ]
yeah and i'm like oh my [ __ ] god like
it sounds wet
yeah
that was one of my most embarrassing
moments my whole life i swear wow so
that your mind automatically goes there
when you think embarrassed huh yeah
cause i might you know when your ears
get [ __ ] hot
and you wish you could disappear but you
you can't like that i'm like oh [ __ ] did
you guys ever go through the phase of
being embarrassed of your parents just
like how they dressed and how they
walked and how they [ __ ] just existed
yeah it's a lot of pressure to have cool
parents
i wonder why everyone goes through that
because like i'm i just like remember
seeing how they dress and i was like dad
can you just please wear a t-shirt like
you're always wearing a [ __ ] button
up like can you be like these dads and
just wear a t-shirt dude my dad would
come on his tiny whites with my friends
around during sleepovers really what the
[ __ ] yeah i'm like what the [ __ ] is with
this guy why did you do this i didn't
give a [ __ ] he didn't give a [ __ ] he's
like it's the weekend i'm not wearing
pants but he's like were you embarrassed
by it was i impressed were you
embarrassed by it
yeah but how old were you though i don't
know like all the way through my teenage
years dude oh [ __ ] high school level
that's [ __ ] horrible but he knows
what he's doing right like he's not yeah
of course yeah his video tapes to prove
it but he's just so used to it i think
because especially because like i had
the same friends around kicking it all
the time yeah so i don't think it's his
home right so he's like this is my
[ __ ] cat i remember um
well um i went to dinner with my friend
and his mom right and his brother and we
came back home and then um his dad's
like a [ __ ] prankster right
and uh
when when we uh when we opened up the
door that fool
was looking at uh like the like the tall
mirrors like those body mirrors or
whatever and then he was flipped
like in like upside down bent over and
he was shaving his ass yeah
what the [ __ ]
for why for what and then he was like
dad what the [ __ ] are you doing
japanese family right so like they just
do pervert jokes and [ __ ] and he goes i
was shaving
and he was in tears crying
he's so i could picture that i was dying
so i pictured this fool he was probably
like waiting for us to come home and as
soon as he heard it pull up that fool
had his butthole wide open and he was
shaving his ass
and and then she was like you're using
my which i think she was using like hers
like [ __ ] blade too and all that and
like
i know but my friend was like [ __ ]
his face went like pale that's hard to
recover from i loved it though dude i
couldn't [ __ ] wait second hand that's
[ __ ] hilarious hilarious yeah it's
not your dad an easy and easy quick
thing that happened to me i was at the
beach when i was 16 with like all my
friends and you know when you're with
your friends you just dare each other to
do stupid [ __ ] we're at the beach i
think it's like at a balsa chica there's
like this girl laying in the sand just
kicking it she looks like she's about
our age and my friend's like oh go
doctor i've never [ __ ] done that in
my life i don't know how to do that
but um they're like one of my friends
manages to talk me into this idea that
it would be cool if i full speed ran and
did a front flip over her to impress her
and she's just what like sunbathing yeah
just chilling oh no and then she dies
that's true this is orion story
i'm sure eventually she died but not
today he doesn't flip and kill the
seagull later she had a final
destination pyramid of things happened
to her
but not now yeah it's not quite a
cinematic it's more this happens to me i
died so like i go and i'm like yeah
that's a good idea because like i was
excited because i could do really good
front flips at the time
so i go i'm like
i go around like this like i'm gonna run
across and i run i'm gonna do a full
speed front tuck it's gonna be dope i
didn't take into account that when your
trunks are wet they get heavier oh
and you're on sand and on my side kind
of sucks you in so as i
launched up i basically jumped out of my
trunks
butt naked oh my god what the [ __ ]
that's true i really was but then the
the sad part is like they didn't come
all the way up they went around my
ankles as i was in the air so i ate [ __ ]
coming down with the pants around your
ankles around my ankle so i just
immediately went like this and put sand
on it and i pulled my shorts up
everybody's like 15 dudes behind dying
laughing
this girl is dying laughing looking me
dead in the eyes like just laughing her
ass off and i i couldn't you know what
if i was if i was who i am today i would
have because it's a [ __ ] great origin
story but i didn't i was i was
legitimately embarrassed i wasn't clever
enough to turn the phrase with your
confidence oh dude [ __ ] yeah i was like
there's no worse thing that could happen
to me but now but hey that woman's name
ryan's wife yeah
her name is ryan's wife crazy crazy damn
i think i got one this i wasn't yeah
okay this one's actually pretty rough
it's probably like [ __ ] [ __ ]
probably no no no no
no this is a good one
so i was eating this watermelon right
yeah uh i think i was like i was by
myself and i've embarrassed myself i was
like i was like should i have dessert
probably i should have dessert
now this was good i i think i was like
24 25 and this is after i started tr i i
was uh we just finished a training
session
and we went to go eat with some of my
teammates
and usually after we're training we're
just like super thirsty so i was like
pounding waters i was like drinking a
bunch of electrolytes and [ __ ]
and uh this is an old town so shout out
to [ __ ] old town
um
i was like okay i have to go get some of
these clothes that we were gonna
put uh heat press for some brands or
whatever so i want to go to h m and i
want to try to get some samples yeah get
some blanks so i went there and i want
to try them on in the bath in in the
dressing room
and
i just finished um trying all the
clothes
and
i was putting my sweats on
i was wearing gray sweats like heather
gray okay like this so you can see you
can see
and all that yeah yeah so that was kind
of sweat i had the sharp pain like in my
in like my bladder area
and i was like what the [ __ ] and then i
started peeing
oh you couldn't control it i just
couldn't i couldn't control it
i started peeing i soaked my [ __ ]
sweats dude in the feeding room in the
fitting room you unhappy what the [ __ ]
does that mean as a kid or whatever no
dude i was 24. i was like
[ __ ] a couple days ago dude
i started you just put it on and it went
dude that could be a serious condition
yeah but it was the only time it
happened so i was like
that's [ __ ] i'm good yeah yeah so i
started peeing my pants and i was like
what the [ __ ]
and you couldn't stop it this is really
good bro i couldn't [ __ ] stop and i
was like jesus christ i'm in the fitting
room like what the [ __ ] am i gonna do
you just drank all that water too well
it's all it's all my [ __ ] pants now
so so you just stole them no no and i'm
like [ __ ] dude so i'm like all right i
have this hoodie how do you i tie it
around to my waist to be like okay this
should be fine right in discretion but
it's but and then this is the [ __ ] up
part i was like hey i came for these
clothes
i already peed my pants i'ma buy these
[ __ ] clothes so i go and eat my piss
[ __ ] stain
in my pistain sweats and i i pay for the
[ __ ] clothes what did you do you just
did you put the tag and you go peep
today's video is brought to you by
audible
listen to the new audio donkey series
funny my way on audible hosted by jb
smoove take a deep dive into the lives
of six
black comedy icons paul mooney flip
wilson mom's maybelline dick gregory
rudy ray moore and red fox hear how
these fearless heroes of black comedy
broke color lines and made it to the top
by doing it their way featuring
commentary from cedric the entertainer
d.l hughley godfrey margaret cho dion
cole sandra bernard and many more listen
on audible now go to audible.com funny
my way no no let me scare you no these
are these are my sweats
oh you put them back on okay yeah yeah
yeah you could do that that works yeah
the clothes that i tried on was a bunch
i went to go i'm waiting in line and
piss-soaked i'm shocked you're you're
willing to buy clothes at this point
yeah no because i was like well [ __ ] it
i'm already here
people paying attention or not i would
imagine yeah like i just felt really
uncomfortable like [ __ ] this is brutal
but was there was there a puddle piss at
the fitting room so i had all my like my
gym bag with me so i just i
i had a towel in there damn you're
pretty nice you cleaned it all up
i cleaned it all up so it was all good i
put it back in my gym bag and i was like
[ __ ] dude this is ridiculous so all i
have is piss soaked [ __ ] uh sweat and
i was trying to smell like do i smell
like bad boys thankfully
it was mostly water thank god still
smell like ammonia though yeah but your
boy is standing in line doug there's
people in behind me there's people in
front of me and i'm waiting i buy the
clothes and i parked on the other side
of colorado you got a good walk of shame
ahead of you so your boy walked probably
like 10 minutes you're your own rose
parade well who's really looking at your
dick
dude
i felt like a lot of people were
like dude
it's heather gray so it's like great
yeah and then it's a dark colored spot
and i have this hoodie and i'm clearly
trying to cover it up but
what do you think it was from like
getting punched in the kidney no it
wasn't even that like i have no to this
day i have no idea and i tell my girl
and i was like super embarrassed walking
back to my car and i was like [ __ ]
i'm gonna own it who gives a [ __ ] like
i'm in this place there's a funny story
i'll tell it later whatever and my
girl's like why didn't you tell like
call me i could have picked you up i was
like no [ __ ] way am i going to call
you to pick me up because i peed my
pants i'm a [ __ ] 25 year old man hey
if you want to [ __ ] get away with it
because you said you have you what i
wanted to get your car 10 minutes took
me 10 minute walk you got to just start
being like
what khan is a real place the
government's [ __ ] covered up you guys
aren't even freaking out
they've been covered for years it's
[ __ ] 100 real you guys know if you
[ __ ] understand how real it is
the gym i worked out was in that area so
it's like i'm
like there's a good shot i'm gonna bump
into someone that i know or like that
would be a nightmare a client
oh my god covered in piss like yeah i
don't think i'm gonna train with you
anymore
dude
i was a kid but still like this one
always sticks with me just because every
time i think about i'm like jesus
[ __ ] christ
um so i was at my friend stanley's
stanley wong's house we were watching
the power rangers
we're probably nine years old
but i'm well beyond potty trained like
probably by like four and a half years
so
all of a sudden i'm just like in his
basement or i'm upstairs with them
watching power rangers and all of a
sudden i think i have to fart and then i
just load my [ __ ] entire jeans up
like load it completely up that's not
your fault dude [ __ ] that's like fall
short ryan's dying right now dude i
completely loaded it up i load it up
you know what i mean dirty diaper yeah
yeah yeah like i filled my shopping cart
i've never heard it would say loaded up
yeah yeah yeah yeah and so i go to check
out
your cart is full yeah the cart's full
so then i'm like oh [ __ ] this is
actually crazy i'm like okay well i live
five houses down and we live in
townhouses right so every house is like
basically linked
but i'm like man i'm so far away i at
least have to like
fix the situation so i'm not like
trailing snail trailing the whole way
home
[Laughter]
so then uh i go downstairs so he's a
basement everyone has a basement and i
go into the basement bathroom their
house is immaculate by the way there's
no reason to ever clean up anything in
this house because it's always beautiful
like it's very minimalist there's really
not much in the house yeah except for
your logs of [ __ ]
okay i'm like
i'm like it's basically commercial time
i could i can
take off my
underwear and like i could probably get
away with this for a while putting my
jacket over
because i had jacob we live like in
in virginia so there's always a reason
to have a jacket
so i was like i'll put my jacket over
like this i could tie it off and but i
but i do it around here
and so i'm and i'm pretty good and then
all i have to do is like kind of cheat
out cheat out and nobody see my butt
cheeks
and then i just got to get home after
this but that's fine like it's close
enough to like it's like dusk-ish i'll
be fine
did you bust one of those who [ __ ]
farted all right that's him
that jojo's coward doing that [ __ ] i
don't do that [ __ ]
technique so i was like all right so i
dispel that [ __ ]
i go back upstairs and then i'm like i'm
just gonna watch power rangers standing
up you know what i mean
bro
i'm like yeah let's finish this thing
off let's see if okay tommy's a green
ranger let's see if he stays that way
and and then he didn't go do you smell
that steve no he honestly just stanley
was [ __ ] oblivious because we're just
into the show we can't believe we all
love the the pink ranger yeah we all
want to have sex with her face yeah so
we'll just wait for more of that
ranger in the meantime
i'm not kidding it's been maybe 37
seconds max
stanley's mother decides
i'm just gonna go clean downstairs
oh
she goes down the [ __ ] stairs and i
hear
a bunch of cantonese
and i'm like oh no because every time
patty starts doing cantonese and a
certain inflection i'm like oh i'm in
trouble because i hear steve i heard
because she she doesn't say
words normally unless it's english and
steven is english so i'm like god damn
it i'm busted she found my underwear i'm
not even kidding it didn't even take
like three minutes oh she [ __ ] zoned
in on that [ __ ] and she already found it
well you hid your underwear in the back
i hid it in the bathroom under the sink
and i just put it under the sink and i
was like i'll collect the shell on my
way out well i was like dude what i'll
do is on the way out i'll just tuck the
[ __ ] in my [ __ ] album
on my way out
you were gonna pocket your [ __ ] how come
you don't want to throw the trash
what
that's my underwear my mom will know if
i don't have underwear yeah dude
guys are forgetting dude bart's been an
adult for too long
he's not connected to neverland she
could probably smell the [ __ ] right and
as a kid you probably had [ __ ] smear on
the handle and she's like what the [ __ ]
i bet it's dripping out of my socks yeah
as a kid you think you're getting away
with murder but you're not probably look
like a tremors trail
so then i do what any self-respecting
young young adult does on the virgin
movie no i start crying immediately
please please please don't tell anybody
please don't [ __ ] tell anybody
and she's like i won't tell anybody but
then of course carol hears about it and
everybody [ __ ] oh no
yeah that doesn't matter
she probably thought it was right i
still went home with my [ __ ] cold
butt cheeks like in the wind
damn
yeah
that's that's a pretty embarrassing one
that was awesome yeah but you were
[ __ ] how old eight it's worse when
you're a kid it's worse when you're 25
years old brother i was getting my dick
sucked four years later dude but at
least now you can
the most embarrassing [ __ ] happens when
you're a kid though because it's like
the end of the world yeah like you know
you guys ever get like embarrassed like
after the fact like years later that
sounds already way too oh like you
realize that you should have been
embarrassed yeah so um i was in high
school and i was playing in the summer
basketball league
and uh
man it already
feels so stupid all right uh this kid
his name's mike right and uh we're in
the summer league together and he was
like a little bit um you know he wasn't
skinny that's all i gotta say fat boy
mike let's go yeah big boy and so we
would always just get into you know when
you're playing basketball people start
talking [ __ ] to each other right and
then there was this thing where you know
when i i would like [ __ ] up or whatever
the [ __ ] happened on the court he'd like
dude how long you talk [ __ ] and you call
me a fat ass right like [ __ ] you dude
you're [ __ ] fat ass right yeah yeah
yeah clap back and he would always be
like what look you're [ __ ] fatter
than me dude and like [ __ ] you you're
the [ __ ] fattest dude here right
there's two fat guys fighting about
two fat guys [ __ ] shaming each other
and it literally wasn't until like after
college that i get hold of like a photo
from like summer league
and i finally found out i was clearly
fatter
you [ __ ] see yourself every day right
you don't know
who you are
it's so good i was just ashamed of
myself for
you for a while
[ __ ] fatty
the fact that you're just in like denial
like oh my god you [ __ ] fat ass cause
i was so confused that he was he must
have been like he was you're fat dude
he's like what the [ __ ]
he must have been like dude anthony's
[ __ ] nuts yeah not just him but
probably everyone on the court was like
this was crazy oh wow
yeah nobody challenged me you're like
this guy's not they're not gonna [ __ ]
with this guy yeah but uh by myself
years later i was extremely embarrassed
or they're like yo it's blimp versus
blimp
it's a blimp off